von hongkong über den nahen und
mittleren osten und europa bis nach
lateinamerika teils monatelange
massenproteste prägten in 2009/10 viele
stadtbildern überrascht und überrumpelte
regierungen wurden zum rücktritt
aufgefordert oder mit verschiedensten
vorwürfen konfrontiert dabei waren die
ursachen die forderungen und
erscheinungsbilder sehr ähnlich heute in
vechta kompakt protestbewegungen 2009
sind egal ob in chile frankreich
algerien im irak oder in hongkong
mutige bürger formierten sich und ließen
ihrer wut enttäuschung oder frustration
freien lauf nicht mehr an autoritären
staaten protestierte mann sondern auch
in gefestigten demokratie
dabei verfolgen die massen keine
ideologischen ziele sondern man erhob
sich gegen politische verhältnisse
soziale missstände oder
regierungsvorhaben in hongkong ging es
vordergründig um ein gesetz das die
auslieferung von angeklagten an das
festland china ermöglichen sollte aber
eigentlich erhob sie qualen die jugend
gegen den wachsenden einfluss pekings
und soziale missstände in afrika stachen
die proteste im sudan hervor die zum
sturz von langzeit präsident al baschir
führten und eine übergangsregierung
brachten in algerien verhinderten
anhaltenden demonstrationen eine weitere
amtsperiode des kreisen präsidenten
es konnte aber kein wirklicher
systemwechsel erzwungen werden
besonders der nahe osten kommt weiterhin
nicht zur ruhe
im irak flammten proteste gegen
ausländische einflussnahme und soziale
missstände auf und bewegten den
premierminister zum rücktritt im iran
wiederum brachte die erhöhung des
benzinpreises die massen auf die straßen
in fragilen libanon der besonders unter
der syrischen flüchtlingslager leidet
richtete sich die wut gegen das
politische system und deren vertreter
ähnlich verhielt es sich in frankreich
wo im vordergrund gegen höhere
treibstoffpreise und pensionsreformen in
den augen vieler aber gegen die
abgehobenheit und bürgerferne der
politischen elite demonstriert wurde in
südamerika kamen zu den aufständen in
venezuela auch massive proteste in
bolivien und chile
dort brachten höhere ticketpreise für
den nahverkehr
das fass zum überlaufen boliviens
präsident evo morales wiederum setzte
sich wegen vorgeworfen wahlmanipulation
ins ausland ab die selbst ernennung
einer oppositionspolitikerin zu
interimspräsidentin löste gleich weitere
proteste aus welche merkmale sind dabei
zu erkennen
die proteste richten sich gegen die
situation im eigenen land sie haben
keinen grenzüberschreitenden charakter
es sind zumeist simple anlässe wie etwa
eine benzinpreiserhöhung eine steuer auf
messenger dienste oder einschnitte im
sozialsystem die massen auf die straßen
treiben die demonstranten verzichten
bewusst auf gewalt auch wenn immer
wieder radikale kräfte ausschreitungen
provozieren
soziale medien ermöglichen die
mobilisierung vieler personen
gleichzeitig können autoritäre systeme
diese technologie als
überwachungsinstrument nutzen
meistens gibt es keine klare
führungsstruktur oder konzepte das ist
problematisch da es keinen
verhandlungsführer gibt der auch
entscheidet wann die geforderten ziele
erreicht sind
daher können proteste trotz einlenkens
der regierung anhalten weil diverse
gruppierungen unterschiedliche
zielsetzungen verfolgen reaktionen der
machthaber diese reichten vom
gesprächsangebot über die blockade des
internet bis zur unterdrückung oder
gewaltsamen niederschlagung von
protesten
so kamen im irak mehr als 500 personen
ums leben selbst in chile waren es über
in zurückhaltung übt sich die führung in
hongkong wo die sicherheitskräfte an
manchen tagen mehr als zwei millionen
demonstranten gegenüber standen
in algerien verzichtete der präsident
auf eine neuerliche kandidatur die
premierminister im libanon und dem irak
traten zurück und im sudan kam es zum
sturz der alten elite und zur bildung
einer übergangsregierung
in hongkong wurde der umstrittene
gesetzesentwurf zurückgezogen
während man in chile die verfassung
änderte und die sozialausgaben deutlich
erhöhte eine kurze bewertung in den
meisten fällen haben die regierungen den
forderungen nachgegeben
das bedeutet aber nicht das tiefer
liegende ursachen erörtert oder
beseitigt wurden
daher bleibt sowohl auf seiten der
eliten wie auch der demonstranten ein
gefühl der verunsicherung denn
misswirtschaft korruption soziale
spannungen oder politische ausgrenzung
lassen sich durch kleinere maßnahmen
nicht beseitigen
dazu kommt dass vielerorts die probleme
eher zunehmen werden zb durch steigende
bevölkerungszahlen dass weitere
auseinanderklaffen der einkommensschere
jugendarbeitslosigkeit oder den sozialen
abstieg gang zur bevölkerungsschichten
ein ausblick die beweggründe die 2009 10
die protestbewegungen antrieben werden
2020 eher zu als abnehmen
in vielen staaten werden sie kompromisse
erzwingen soziale veränderungen bewirken
und auch politische machtwechsel
herbeiführen können
bislang handelte es sich bei den
demonstrationen und proteste nicht um
revolutionen
wenn sich aber die grundsätzlichen
verhältnisse nicht ändern kann es auch
zu revolutionen und zum gewaltsamen
sturz von regierungen und eliten kommen
[Musik]